hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot I'm
still going I didn't even take a break I
didn't even take a breather I didn't
need one
remember how cool and calm and collected
I am that's how I'm gonna go into this
next few set of levels so I know I know
you guys are all like hey this
markiplier guy seems out of his goddamn
mind you're right about that I'm out of
my gourd but that's okay cuz I'm back in
the seat and we don't have to do a god
damn well that was I gotta stop rushing
into things and I gotta start going
forward with my feelings
no again I was just about to go forward
without my feelings
God have my feelings in my bag before I
go ready and jump off a ledge Oh Frick
okay oh that's a nice jump oh that's a
faith jump what are wrong with you old
man you okay what are you feeling for oh
okay I guess we're going now oh okay oh
you know what I'm not gonna do no this
was bad timing okay but it worked out
for me I'm gonna jump on you I worked it
worked that bird died and saved me
worthy sacrifice eh why didn't I wait
till I got to the bottom before I tried
to jump in the hole I don't know I'm
just so eager to get in that hole good
alright carrying on as if nothing
happened
do you want to run that by me again oh I
hate getting these boxes over and over
again I don't even care about the
completionist [ __ ] but I got to do
it in my brain some body once told me
the world was gonna roll me
okay don't just stop grabbing you
looking weird oh ah I almost didn't make
that that would have been cool if I
didn't make that right remember we're
out fun and happy it is whenever I fail
and everyone's like eyes man
yeah you remember that Myrna the good
old days
wait till I get to the bottom and then
go in the hole wasn't high enough it
wasn't high enough guys guys did you
know did you know it wasn't high enough
guys did you hear the new boots have you
heard the good word it wasn't high
enough to be able to get in there I
wasn't high enough for this game I'm not
high enough freakin why why why you oh
[ __ ] you were done
why's your him so goddamn lethal why all
right you know what I'm just gonna you
[ __ ] oh I guess [ __ ] this game over so
why can't we do it again because that
because there's a strategy then I can
get more game like this game lives I'm
barely in the beginning of goddamn level
and I can't get through it
what's wrong with me I'm a better gamer
than this here all you laughing don't do
that I did it again again again I did it
again oh no I want to play the game I
don't want to be bad that's what I don't
want to do no stop again like I don't
know what it is about me that's just
like go go right it'll all work out in
the end
what you don't need to wait why wait
take it take your chance take your one
opportunity
remember if you only add one chance one
opportunity would you take it don't miss
your chance to blow is what I'm saying
just have you got an opportunity to blow
whoa
like he said you gotta blow her mom's
sphaghetti remember remember mom's
spaghetti
t-shirt spaghetti already mom's
spaghetti you're nervous are you talking
to yourself yeah I think I am actually
oh great that's what I've been doing in
all my Let's Plays people think I'm
talking to the camera that's talking to
myself it's not worth it I'm not gonna
go for that would been the bad timing
anyway so great
am I just on the wrong circuit I'm on
the wrong one aren't I
okay wait no I think if I wait a little
longer I think if I wait yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's Turtles all over again ah turtles
in time
oh go faster okay great oh these
bastards have I even hit a checkpoint
yet I don't think I have why are there
so many identical twins in here where's
my goddamn checkpoint if you don't give
me a goddamn checkpoint soon have I hit
one I don't even remember I could have
blacked out and you know I wouldn't have
been able to I I have no idea where I
Who am I Who am I okay oh this looks bad
got the timing though got the timing oh
you Bertram you if you don't give me a
goddamn checkpoint I swear I'm gonna
kill everyone no why am i down here now
no oh no oh no I have to okay I don't
like that
okay but we made it
still no checkpoint don't know why don't
know why no checkpoint go no oh no oh no
that's not right please tell me a bird's
gonna come back Oh convenient point yes
okay I don't I don't want that
no no no no no no no no why no
checkpoint why why would you do that to
a human being why would you that's so
cruel oh my god oh my god I was thinking
about the quick ones
up ahead oh my god how can they do this
to human how can they do this to a
person
these know hey you're brighter now I can
see your face wink okay so far so good
no god damn it it's so close it's so
close how do you do that oh whoa okay I
made it I don't know how but I made it
okay still no checkpoint great made it
though whoa why is there no checkpoints
crime against humanity crime crime crime
crime crime that's not a checkpoint
that's an outlet please let me have that
don't do anything dickish Lee before I
get there please don't I'm begging you I
can smell the ticket tree okay
I cannot believe that okay but
everything's fine cuz I'm cool calm and
collected most importantly of all I'm
collected I feel good about life I feel
good about life I'm lying I'm lying lies
lies I feel good I'm lying that's not
right the timing is off it's all I have
the timing is Earth
if the timing is F ah oh yes I like bags
of dicks I like bags of them I like bag
dicks bag dicks are my favorite what's
this blue Stover there ooh
why sir why Sir sir why you don't have
an infinite supply that's not how
science and or physics works oh I
thought maybe okay you wiggly wobbly
bastards Yoshiki okay doing great I'm in
the flow of it I think I feel good again
lies lies lies again lies I tell lies to
make myself feel better I'll feel better
I'm just doing a warm-up guys I don't
know what you're talking about vocal
warm-ups and all that okay oh boy it's
me again somehow I made it all the way
up here I'm really moving up in life oh
no that was the easy why do I die there
why there I panic I have a freaking
extra shield on me and I panic oh why
the [ __ ] losing it I'm losing it I was
so calm I was so in the zone and then I
lose it on the old guys just flailing
like a bunch of God again not again this
time not ever not ever again never again
are you'll pieces of [ __ ] I don't have
an extra hit for this so don't [ __ ]
hit me
oh yeah yeah yeah I don't understand
that but okay I thought I was dead for
sure but all right you okay hey what the
hell is this bonus area I've never been
here before let's find let's go on an
adventure what is this I don't like this
I don't like this I'm just going oh well
well well well well well Bubba Bubba
Bubba 1 well at least I get to do this
one again that's great
ok cool all right cool
oh yes please I'm not crazy right
the difficulty ramped up a lot what's
wrong I
why can't I make that why am i making
that jump why am I not making that
there's no excuse for this there's a
freaking bonus round I should be bad
Oh again what's going on happening there
we go yeah there we go
no my bonuses no my boat my bonuses ah
my bonuses it's fine didn't need it ah
that's a lot of lives actually you just
blew up I don't know why you blew up
thank you for the lives nonetheless I
ain't gonna ask too many questions about
that alright carrying on I think that
acts as a checkpoint so I think I'm
saved no wrong come back to me that are
you going where you going Bonnie where
you go I'm not going for that oh I
should I should but I'm not I got lives
in the bonus round so I guess I'm gonna
be fine let go oh man oh you're such a
tease of the jeez
yes no this was wrong but I guess we're
fun oh don't let me die to him don't let
me die to him do not even they know that
this level was [ __ ] oh I don't even
feel like you're overjoyed when I beat
it finally the enemies such an
anticlimactic piece of Garbo oh man I'm
never gonna finish this game if this
what's gonna take if this is how this is
gonna go but everybody so much for
watching hope you've been enjoying it
I'm gonna keep going yeah I really am
oh this better be like the last island I
don't even know if it is so either way
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know how I'm doing in the
comments below
I know terribly or amazingly
perseverance is everything right so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]